The correlation coefficient now goes down to 0.231, which is a lot lower than
this one. As you can see, r is sensitive to outliers just like the mean is. In
other words, outliers can dramatically change the value of r. That's why it's
important to look at data with a critical eye and think, what is causing this
outlier to be there? Should we include it in the measurement of our statistics?
Remember how before, when we created box plots, we looked at just the
interquartile range, and outliers weren't used in the actual box-and-whisker
plot. They were drawn as circles on the outside. Kind of like this. Sometimes
it's good to take outliers into account. Other times, you want to see the trend
of the data without them.